[Musik]
das war ein fahrzeug für 310 ihm zuvor
technisches produkt wie gesagt wir haben
mit unserem gerät vor dem kampf zwischen
belasteten gelände und dann wird minen
räumen oder kampfmittel prasselte
flächen einfach bearbeiten damit noch
andere maschinen dieses gelände nutzen
keiner weiter bearbeiten können oder
dass man dafür nicht
das gerät hat 19 tonnen und eine räum
breite vertreter 50 euro zwei werken
motoren mit jeweils knapp 190 ps und
zwei mann besatzung unsere
einsatzgebiete sind bewusst und blut
muss bereit sein stärker zusammen
arbeiten verschiedene branchen streifen
wildflecken und den schießbahnen damit
ein schießt auf diesen möglich ist und
natürlich auch vorgesehen in
verschiedenen ausland szenarien oder
fans einsetzen
[Musik]
doch hinter mir sind die fahrerkabine
geglückt zwei mann besatzung und der
fahrrad und sieht schon gedreht und
somit in die richtige richtung der
einrichtung
womit anfangs oder zwei motoren
dies wird diese wieder streifen jim
bezeichnet der rest wird als farbig
gekennzeichnet so mit zwei maschinen die
getrennt voneinander bedienbar sind
der große vorteil von maschinen vor ort
kann mit der zweiten maschine die
maschine wieder zusammen mit liegen und
den gefahrenbereich verlassen so hinter
mir jetzt das neue werk von trainer auf
diesem berg befinden sich 74
verschiedene arten andere für die
vegetation für die minenräumung selbst
und ganz dahinter meinte flecker brett
der mit dem die maschine geschützt ist
so dass vor der detonation kommen
[Musik]